all right this is a story that I uh that
has mostly passed me by I haven't really
paid close attention to it
um as important as it obviously is so
I'm kind of learning about it as we read
and uh maybe you're learning about it as
well
here's the latest from deadline
uh Prince Harry Meghan Markle and
markle's mother Doria Ragland were
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase near catastrophic involving
Paparazzi photographers last night
according to a spokesperson for the
prince we're told the trio did not go to
the hospital and that they're doing okay
well that's good it's very worried the
incident has been reported by Reuters
and Sky News and allegedly happened
after Harry and wife Markle attended an
awards ceremony in New York on Tuesday
during which Markle received a woman of
vision award
what is her vision exactly
that's that's the real news here a woman
of vision award
um where is there evidence that Meghan
Markle has a vision that extends Beyond
her reflection in the bathroom mirror
that's the only Vision I think she's
thinking about in a statement from the
prince's representative it says last
night the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and
Miss Raglan were involved in a near
catastrophic car chase at the hands of a
ring of Highly aggressive Paparazzi this
Relentless Pursuit lasting over two
hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers while being a public figure
comes with a level of interest from the
public it should never come at the cost
of anyone's safety
the incident which comes just over a
week after Harry attended his father
King Charles this coronation London has
horrible shades of the way in which
Harry's mother Princess Diana died in
the late 1990s in Paris some media blame
the erratic behavior of the paparazzi
um as the cause of the fatal crash and
so it's almost as if it happened again
we're told with this high-speed
car chase in New York City now
um when I just first reaction reading up
on this story
a number of problems immediately arise
the first one is what do you mean near
catastrophic
okay what you're saying is nothing
happened there was no Collision
but you're saying it was nearly a
catastrophic how could it be it's one
thing to say I almost got into an
accident but you're it was not only to
almost contact him but it was almost
catastrophic
so nothing happened it's like you've got
nothing and then you have catastrophe
and you've skipped over all the things
in between and gone right so it was
almost a catastrophe
so that doesn't make a lot of sense to
me and then also how
would that work exactly you know I've
spent more time in New York City than uh
I I have ever wanted to spend
and one of the many things about New
York City that's just god-awful is the
traffic and the fact that
you know if you have to go somewhere and
it's a mile and a half away
and usually you would think oh it's a
mile halfway I'll get in the car you
know five minutes ahead of time I'll be
there on time no mile and a half is
going to take you about six and a half
hours
so with with traffic that jammed up how
could there be
a high-speed chase
and especially one that lasts for two
hours
this would have to be I mean we're
talking about Fast and Furious type of
thing like this is a this is an action
movie to be I guess there's a way to do
it there's a way to engage in a
high-speed chase but you have to be you
have to be like a professional Stunt
Driver in order to find uh to weave your
way in and out of New York traffic so it
sounds like a little bit of an odd story
um in fact it sounds completely
unbelievable and then all the updates
start coming in uh with other people who
are around this and saw this and and
pretty much all of them are saying no
it's uh it was it was totally fine they
were in a cab for part of this high
speed chase and the cab drivers come out
and said no it was it was basically
normal it was fine it was everything was
fine
um daily wire has an update for the New
York police department so at the New
York Police Department responded on
Wednesday to reports that Prince Harry's
wife Meghan Markle and her mother Dori
Raglan were involved in a near
catastrophic car chase uh NYPD Deputy
Commissioner public information officer
Julian Phillips issued a statement to
the Daily wire confirming that the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex were escorted by
officers while in the city but said that
there were there were no collisions or
injuries involved in their transport uh
says quote on Tuesday evening May 16th
the NYPD assisted the private security
team protecting the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex there were numerous photographers
that made their transport challenging
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex arrived
at their destination and there were no
reported collisions summonses injuries
or arrests in that regard
um
and
other Witnesses have said including uh
uh the mayor of New York has come out
and said it's it's hard to it's hard to
believe that that would have happened
again anyone who's familiar with New
York City knows that there's no there
are no two-hour high-speed car chases
happening in the middle of New York City
the first step in growing up and being a
real man is getting off your parents
phone plan one of the first steps anyway
there's other things too but getting
your own cell phone plan gives you a
sense of Independence and responsibility
it's a step towards becoming more
self-sufficient by paying for your own
finances you'll learn how to budget and
manage your money there are a ton of
cell phone providers out there
unfortunately most of them want to lock
you into horrific contracts that will
tack on hidden fees at any chance they
get that's why I'm a huge fan of pure
talk there are no contracts no hassle
you can cancel at any time Pure Talk is
also giving you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy
phone when you sign up for the 55 per
month unlimited plan plus hot spot today
they use the exact same networks as
major carriers so you get the same
coverage that you're used to but it's
just a much better service and lot
cheaper too switching over to Pure Talk
is so easy you can make the switch keep
your cell phone number and keep your
phone number and you can do all of this
in as little as 10 minutes with their
us-based customer service team Pure Talk
is so short you're going to love your
service they're backing up with a 100
money back guarantee so go to
puretalk.com enter promo code Walsh just
say 50 off their first month with pure
talk that's puretalk.com promo code
Welsh short talk is simply smarter
Wireless so this is a a story that they
invented
not the first time that they've invented
a story
but it is it is
it's really extraordinary that they feel
the need to stoop to this level
I mean this is uh this is full on Jessie
Smollett this is basically a Justice
Millet moment
and what makes it Jesse smallett is it's
not so much the
the thing that they're claiming is it's
a different sort of thing and as far as
I know they're not claiming that the
paparazzi had Mega hats and were chasing
them down and saying this is Maga
country
so they're not saying that but it's
similar just as well in just how
unbelievable it is like if you're
familiar at all with the area anyone who
knew anything about Chicago if you even
if you didn't spend a lot of time there
if you've spent any time in Chicago you
you immediately knew as soon as you
heard the Justice bullet story okay uh 2
A.M in the winter in Chicago and you're
walking for a sandwich that doesn't make
any sense
Trump supporters and Maga hats hanging
out outside in Chicago at night also
doesn't make any sense
um and same thing here with this story
in New York it's if you're at all if you
have any common sense at all especially
if you're familiar with these areas uh
the story doesn't even begin to hold
water
and yet they make up the story anyway
because they are they are so desperate
to be victims
and this this psychological
pull towards victimhood
for Harry and Megan is uh overwhelming
they can't they can't see outside of it
when
in in reality it's like they they have
really nice comfortable
lives the kind of lives that most people
most people would kill to have a life
like this like you know you're rich you
don't have to do anything you can just
like your whole job is just to be famous
and Rich
live in a beautiful house all these
things
and and you would you would think well
why can't you just accept that I can
accept the fact that you have a nice
easy comfortable life why can't you
accept that
stop denying it acceptance
is the only path to happiness here
this is true for anyone you know if you
want to be happy in life you have to it
has to begin with acceptance you have to
accept you have to uh uh you know
realize where you are in life and accept
reality for what it is
but for a lot of people they struggle to
accept reality for what it is because
sometimes the reality can be is quite
painful
you know it's like if you just got
diagnosed with a terminal illness or
something and well it doesn't mean that
you can't have happiness but it has to
begin by accepting you have to accept
the fact that that happened and not try
to hide from it
um and it makes sense that it'd be
difficult to accept
things that are hard but for Harry and
Megan they they have difficulty
accepting the good stuff
that you have a a good life
and a comfortable luxurious life
but a lot of this is also cultural and
we know that in our culture
um
Prestige and power comes from victimhood
and Prestige and power is what they both
crave most of all especially Megan
and she knows that she can't really have
it without also being a victim and so
she will try anything to attain that
victimhood status they'll do it for this
portion of shows and move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed